hi my name is nicole beyer and i feel
giddy about being conan o'brien's friend
that's so nice whenever someone pauses
at that point i have fear
that it's going to be something negative
and then giddy i'll take giddy yeah we
should uh for full disclosure reveal
that you're drinking the most
caffeinated drink and so it may not be
me that's making you giddy
what's in that bad boy
it is a venti iced coffee
light ice four shots of espresso and
sugar-free vanilla and then if you
really want a party you do two shots of
tequila
wait what what what happens if you
combine tequila and coffee i don't
you're getting your body's getting so
many mixed signals uh-huh but it's a fun
time and then you get in the pool and
then
when you do a podcast yeah then you're
resuscitated it's in the bottom of the
pool
you come back again it's a good time
you come back as a really hyperactive
ghost hey guys what's going on
ghost take it easy okay
i can't help it
i died with too much caffeine that's how
i'm gonna be uh wow uh well okay is this
your normal thing because
i was commenting when you came in uh you
are extremely busy you're a very busy
person and i'm happy for you because
everything's going your way
uh and but i mean you're doing so much
right now and you're handling it okay
yes okay you're gonna pause and think
about it okay sometimes i get real tired
and okay so i recorded a podcast with my
best friends to share it's called best
friends and uh we had a live show and at
the live show i was like this year did
we record this week i literally don't
remember and she was like yeah we had to
put a disclaimer at the top to say that
you were really tired
i truly don't remember doing it and
before we started i do like vaguely
remember sitting in front of my computer
being like and kimmy our producer being
like do you want to do this another day
and i was like i'm here let's do it and
then i listen to the episode i sound
like i'm in slow-mo
well first of all how are you right now
are you going to remember this
appearance on this podcast you will
you're present yes i went to sleep at
midnight 30.
midnight 30. yes so i'm good well rested
good good one and uh because you know
what i can not i've known you for a
number of years
you're one of my favorite all-time
guests because you are alone
seriously
first of all no one sings my name like
you do
uh um that that conan song you do oh
it's just amazing um
and failed to chart for reasons we don't
understand it's the lyrics it's the
lyrics
any other name
that would have done much nigel up the
charts number one
you